[Musique]
on trouve toujours facilement cet
endroit zaba line la ville des
ramasseurs de déchets se distingue par
une odeur âcre insupportable pour la
plupart des gens c'est là qu'on amène
les déchets de tous les coins du caire
il n'y a pas d'armé ou deux polices ici
les gens vivent selon leurs propres
règles et ne sont pas toujours très
heureux de voir des étrangers
ici on trouve principalement des
chrétiens coptes religions minoritaires
en egypte des musulmans y vivent aussi
mais il n'y a pas de conflit religieux à
baline les déchets qui garantisse la
paix inter confessionnel car ils sont le
seul fournisseur de travail et de moyens
de subsistance
[Musique]
kirollos saad
à 10 ans il a passé son enfance dans la
ville des ramasseurs de déchets de sa
balle in mais il a de la chance
contrairement à d'autres enfants de son
âge
kirilow snap a encore dû commencer à
faire le sale boulot je ne veux pas que
mon fils face aux london de balle parce
que ma femme travaille donc signé fait
toutes les femmes de ma famille
travaille de manière générale les
enfants commencent à aider les adultes
quand ils ont entre 10 et 12 ans parfois
même plus tôt si leur famille est
vraiment dans le besoin et on peut donc
voir beaucoup d'enfants plus jeune que
le mien travailler goergl a hérité de ce
travail de son père qui était aussi
ramasseurs de déchets ils se sont
installés à zaba line il y à 45 ans les
techniques de recyclage ont à peine
changé depuis
[Musique]
la famille de gaza d' collecte tri et
nettoie plusieurs types de déchets à la
fois en règle générale les hommes
s'occupent du métal et du plastique
cette machine nettoie le plastique
et celle ci le mois
la première le nettoie et la seconde le
bois ensuite celle ci le sèche avant
qu'ils ne soient broyés en poudre enfin
nous le mettons dans des sacs et
l'envoyons l usine
[Musique]
ah l'amour
maintenant ces déchets vont être vendues
à quelqu'un qui va l'étrier pour la
seconde fois et tout sera recyclé une
partie sera transformé en cuillère en
plastique
voilà à quoi il ressemble
[Musique]
la collecte et le tri des ordures sont
une affaire familiale
les femmes montrent également le rôle à
jouer el tri des déchets alimentaires
[Musique]
nous vivons en dehors du reste de la
ville
nous sommes tous indépendants tout le
monde ne pense pas du mal de nous il ya
des gens qui respectent notre travail
mais je comprends les gens chez qui nous
suscitons du dégoût notre travail est
épuisant nous sommes très fatigués après
une journée de travail
nous avons souvent des problèmes de dos
nous transportons parfois des sacs de 50
kg jusqu'au cinquième étage puis il faut
les redescendre
c'est un travail épuisant
chirat telle mort à 10 est l'une des
personnes les plus riches de sa balle in
il aime se considérer comme le maire de
la ville des ramasseurs de déchets mais
officiellement un tel poste n'existe pas
selon certaines rumeurs cheratte à
contrôler personnellement la vente de
toute la vérité aux recycleurs ceux qui
sont heureux lui permet d'engranger des
profits fabuleux
il ya une villa avec un luxueux
pigeonnier tout près de l'entrée de la
déchetterie shehata ne touche jamais aux
ordures lui même qui ne fait que gérer
le processus il ne s'occupe même pas de
la propreté de sa propre maison
il a une femme de ménage pour ça
[Musique]
qu'attendez-vous du gouvernement nous
avons besoin de véhicules modernes pour
transporter les déchets de la ville vers
la déchetterie un équipement moderne et
sûre si le gouvernement approuve le
projet de traitement des déchets
ce sera tout à fait positif pour les
ramasseurs là que nos corps sont
couverts de bactéries nous sommes nés de
pères qui eux aussi ramasser des ordures
azabal in les microbes et bactéries des
déchetteries sont déjà en nous mais ils
ne font que renforcer notre système
immunitaire contre les maladies
si j'étais un citoyen ordinaire je ne
ressemblerait pas ça aujourd'hui chez
qatar c'est mon oncle il a réussi sa vie
ouais mais son père était très riche à
l'origine la communauté est composé à 90
% de pauvres
il s'agit de ramasseurs ordinaire qui
dépendent de leur collecte des déchets
qu'ils ramassent qu'ils trient et qu'ils
vendent pour être recyclés comme vous le
voyez ici les familles tri et là des
gens compact le papier le compact avec
un compacteur électrique compact on mène
notre propre vie gonano épicerie quand
nos boucherie nos cafés parce que les
gens ont besoin de se reposer après
avoir ramassé des déchets alors ils
viennent au café pour boire un thé ou
fumé un narguilé
[Musique]
et l'épreuve le problème ou conflits qui
surgit entre eux est résolu en interne
par les chefs de famille ici nous
respectons les personnes âgées
quand il y a un problème les personnes
âgées se réunissent et en parle ensemble
non vous devez vous excuser devant lui
vous dites je suis désolé mais ça suffit
le problème est résolu nous n'allons
jamais à la police nous ne faisons
jamais venir les policiers ils le font
qu'aggraver les problèmes
la mine a récemment eu une dispute avec
un voisin
ils sont venus chez nous et ont commencé
à tirer avec leurs armes
enfin moi avons été blessés
nous avons dû aller à l'hôpital c'était
sérieux comme nous avons eu peur pour
nos enfants pour qu'ils puissent être
qui n'a fait en sorte ensuite nous avons
réglé la question
nous avons fait la paix à l'église avant
ne pas trop vite arrivé nous sommes
arrivés à une solution à lyon ne s'est
jamais reproduit de la sorte
les coptes disent être parmi les
premiers chrétiens du monde
ils croient que leurs ancêtres se sont
convertis quand jésus était encore en
vie ils ont toujours depuis lors essayez
de résoudre les problèmes pacifiquement
de manière chrétienne
[Musique]
la bible dit que tout le monde devrait
vivre en paix que des enfants de dieu
ils vont bien que les gens ne feront
confiance grâce à mon sourire parce
qu'ils estimeront que je ne trompera
personne et voir mon amour pour jésus
quand je parle à quelqu'un on dit que si
vous voyez une personne qui marche et
vous sourit ligne après avoir dénoncé m
alors vous avez rencontré un vrai
chrétien
bon
comme ça
content mais attendez
amman et embrasser la croix
[Musique]
je l'aï bien vous n'êtes pas censés
l'amateur retouches
[Musique]
ça
rené minart mine à les sortir les
ouedraogo
une gare est à fillon
[Musique]
sortir les pigeons
ce sont nos pigeons au milieu là là au
milieu c'est génial et là ce sont des
oisillons regardent ils sont noirs et
jaunes
et
[Musique]
vous pouvez en faire un plat savoureux
j'en mange avec du riz au lait vous avez
déjà essayé le quartier est plein de
pigeons regarder non seulement il y en a
beaucoup c'est un sport un hobby mais un
passe-temps pour la moitié du quartier
regardez là ce sont tous des pigeons
[Musique]
et
pour gaza d' la journée de travail
commence à 3h30
[Musique]
chaque habitant 2 à baline à une zone de
la capitale égyptienne sous sa
responsabilité la collecte des déchets
sur le territoire d'un collègue
est strictement interdite tous les
ramasseurs respecte scrupuleusement les
règles tacites
fait ça tous les jours je ramasse tout
type d'ordures déchets alimentaires
papiers divers boîtes bouteilles tout
type de plastique
je travaille tous les jours sauf le
dimanche
je ramasse les ordures auprès de chaque
maison et je dépose dans mon véhicule
d'une guerre fut nous rentrons à la
maison avec mon fils dans son très bon
hockey fils c'est bon pour aujourd'hui
[Musique]
block est regardée chaque tonne de
déchets ces cinq emplois directs pour
deux personnes font la collecte de porte
en porte une se charge du transport et
deux filles donc pour commencer cela
fait cinq emplois puis il ya sept
emplois indirects
ceux qui recyclent le papier le
plastique le métal verre donc au caire
pour chaque tonne d'ordures
ces douze emplois bribes et
voyez il ya aussi des choses comme ça
dans les ordures c'est du maquillage des
marques ça ça doit être un truc pour les
massages vous savez de quel genre de
massage il s'agit non c'est pas du tout
elle le sait elle m'a dit de lire
attentivement ce qui avait marqué dessus
vous le savez vous c'est pour les femmes
pour les hommes
ces choses deviennent des poubelles saut
d'essai alors ils vendent ces petites
choses les gens vont au marché et il
crie comme ça venez par ici venez par et
s'ils ne volaient pas ou vous irez en
enfer
venez acheter vieil homme qui achète
[Musique]
et
ça coûte 10 livres dits libres mais
s'est cassé
donne moi un autre pays
quatre livres 4 lille entre moi l'argent
c'est le plus gros marché du vendredi du
caire il est situé près de la cité des
ramasseurs de déchets les gens viennent
acheter des cadeaux pour leurs proches
et tout ce qui peut être nécessaire à la
maison avec ma voiture je vais partout
en ville et je crie apportez moi vos
vieilles affaires je ne me suis jamais
considéré comme quelqu'un d'important
mais grâce au président si si nous le
sommes
notre président est comme ça as tu un
homme un vrai j'en suis sûr
là bas que je gagne 2 à 3 millions de
livres par mois
en vrai nom mille les parents de
kirollos ne lui achète pas de jouer il
peut trouver tout ce qui l'intéresse à
la déchetterie cela permet d'économiser
de l'argent
[Musique]
de retour chez gaza d' nous rencontrons
le propriétaire de la boucherie samir
fatigué je vais vous montrer regarder
tout ça c'est de la nourriture pour les
cochons
[Musique]
il est difficile d'imaginer trouver des
cochons dans un pays musulman mais les
coptes sont chrétiens et le port fait
partie de leur alimentation
[Musique]
je vais insister sur le fait qu'il n'y a
pas de conflit entre chrétiens et
musulmans
la source du terrorisme n'est pas là
nous vivons ensemble et nous faisons
affaire ensemble nous mangeons ensemble
la plupart de mes voisins sont chrétiens
elle avait votre religion et moi la
mienne mais les ignorants ne
l'accepterons jamais ouais c'est sûr
[Musique]
à la chaîne domicile vous les verrez
maintenant
[Musique]
les porcs sont les amis de l'homme et
lorient des savoureuses comme ces lois
je les cuis
[Applaudissements]
d'abord nous les posons ici nous les
amenons dans un atelier par la regarder
et pas un cochon égyptiens au brésil
c'est un brésilien
vous voyez qu'il ya un long museau et
cela et c'est par le museau que vous
voyez que c'est une race brésilienne à
partir de 1990 j'ai travaillé comme
chauffeur de bus pour une agence de
voyages ensuite le tourisme a décliné
brusquement et j'ai dû me mettre à cette
activité là bas ça j'ai rencontré plein
de gens différents
quand je vous ai vus j'ai tout de suite
compris que vous étiez russe même si je
ne parle pas de langue étrangère ces
russes ça se reconnaît
il faut tout faire avec intelligence le
ps d'avion d' avant de la faire cuire
pour estimer combien d'argent je vais
gagner
je ne prends aucun risque dans les
affaires ça pèse 11 kg
essayez
soit
j'ai tout mélangé avec des épices quand
il fera noir jeu mettra le grill en
route il n'y a pas si longtemps le port
était interdite en egypte la majorité
parlementaire des frères musulmans avait
décidé de faire abattre tout le bétail
du pays y compris les ports appartenant
aux chrétiens 2 à baline à cette époque
là bas lui les ramasseurs de déchets 2 à
baline avait commencé par trier les
déchets organiques dans le centre ville
et à les mettre dans des conteneurs de
multinationales dans les grandes rues du
caire donc les rues du caire était sale
il y avait une odeur épouvantable
cela a duré deux ans jusqu'à la
révolution du 21 janvier
et puis ça a été de retour à la normale
à la baline si le président est hors du
pays le premier ministre ou le vice
président peut le remplacer mais s'il
n'y a plus de ramasseurs au caire
personne ne peut les remplacer
le caire en mourait
[Musique]
la famille de gaza ne mange rarement de
la viande de porc ou de boeuf une fois
par semaine seulement le dimanche
il s'agit d'un mais très cher cela leur
coûte entre 50 et 100 livres égyptiennes
par kilo soit entre 5 et 10 dollars
combien dépense et vous pour vous
nourrir ne comptant pas parmi nous
achetons divers aliments
il est impossible de mesurer sa
exactement par exemple un petit déjeuner
pour tout le monde peut coûter 10 livres
nous faisons des oeufs et les frites un
déjeuner peut coûter 25 lits
nous mangeons trois fois par jour parce
que nous travaillons beaucoup petit
déjeuner déjeuner dîner dont on nous dit
non à 19h 20h quand le travail est
terminé notre travail très dur mais nous
dans un autre pays et nous mettrons cet
endroit
il ya une école locale azabal in mais
cela ne garantira pas acquis rhinos une
éducation qui lui permettrait de faire
autre chose que la collecte et le tri
des ordures
les enfants étudient leur langue
maternelle et les mathématiques
mais les courts de tri des ordures ont
tendance à l'emporter sur les autres
matières depuis l'ouverture de l'école
seuls trois ou quatre personnes ont
réussi à échapper à la déchetterie les
autres n'ont pas eu d'autre choix que de
rester vivre et travailler ici
comment pouvez-vous vivre dans de telles
conditions c'est notre vie que pouvons
nous faire
je vais décider de notre destin
qu'il en soit ainsi je peux vous montrer
comment nous nous débrouillons faso
seringue et objets pointus
vous n'avez pas peur d'attraper une
infection
que faire il faut subvenir à nos besoins
nous rêvons d'aller à l'étranger
je fais partie de ces gens je trouve un
travail à l'étranger j'y vais n'importe
quel travail
vous vous souvenez de ciudad qui étaient
avec nous plutôt une aiguille de cette
taille lui entré dans la main il a percé
son doigt ici alors tout son corps
pourri je me suis piqué doit ce matin
c'est bon j'ai pressé la plaie il ya eu
un peu de surplus voilà nous sommes des
animaux
il y à 70 environ des agriculteurs ont
quitté leur terre et sont venus ici
depuis ils n'ont pas d'autres emplois
c'est pourquoi quand vous leur parlez
d'infection ils disent c'est pas grave
on a une bonne immunité alors qu'au
contraire on a des problèmes de santé
ici plus de 42% de la communauté à des
hépatites b et c
on a également beaucoup de maladies de
peau nous payons ce travail très cher
nous le payons de notre santé de notre
vie ici l'espérance de vie ne dépasse
pas 50 5 ans les gens meurent très jeune
je
[Musique]
c'est un endroit préféré non pourquoi
mais j'ai marqué je peux tomber du toit
quel est ton plus grand rêve dans la vie
kirollos je vais être médecin et quitter
cet endroit
je ne veux pas que mon fils finisse
comme moi je veux qu'ils aient une vie
meilleure que la mienne mais aucun
travail mais on te qui honteux c'est de
rester à la maison et de vivre aux
crochets des autres demandiez où deux
volets la bible dit que si vous
travaillez dur je vous aurai toujours du
pain
[Musique]
je
[Applaudissements]